[Musica]
[Applauso]
c'è un libro della giornalista e
scrittrice che il primo run che è uscito
qualche anno fa che in originale si
intitola aut b a woman come essere una
donna
lo diceva già simon de beauvoir negli
anni 40 donne non si nasce non si
diventa donne non è una condizione
preesistente non è qualcosa che sei e
basta donne un processo con degli step
quasi tutti obbligatorie donna prima
ancora che un cosa è un come fra le
tante cose difficili che si possono fare
essendo una donna quella che sto facendo
io in questo momento è una delle più
difficili in assoluto parlare per 10 12
minuti senza essere interrotta
preferibilmente da un uomo è una specie
di evento eccezionale
[Applauso]
e quando lo fai notare c'è quasi sempre
un uomo che ti interrompe per dire che
non è vero io sono nata nel 1972
all'epoca una gravidanza era un po una
ciocca sorpresa che io sarei stata
femmina i miei l'hanno scoperto nel
momento preciso della mia nascita lungo
un minuto prima non hanno avuto 4 5 mesi
per proiettarli addosso le loro fantasie
di come sarei stata sono nata ero
piccoletta secca calva e femmina sono
una femmina cis gender ovvero se
pensiamo al genere come una collina da
scavallare non è proprio così
facciamo come se io mi trovo già ai
piedi del lato che mi corrisponde sono
di qua sono cis comunque nasci e 6 chi
più chi meno femmina e passi buona parte
della tua vita a imparare a diventare
una donna è un processo di addizione e
sottrazione per lo più di sottrazione
perché per essere una donna con la d
maiuscola come cantava carmen consoli
bisogna imparare a togliere essere meno
meno rumorose e meno disordinate meno
esuberanti meno disinvolte se poi una
aspira la qualifica di signora la
sottrazione si fa estrema la signora la
vera signora elegante e l'eleganza
minimalismo asciuttezza rinuncia essere
donna significa anche e soprattutto
imparare a occupare meno spazio nel
mondo la magrezza non è associata alla
bellezza per questioni di salute come si
racconta nel grasso fobici lasciate
perdere parte che della salute altrui e
la gente non frega assolutamente nulla
il problema è la percezione del corpo
femminile come qualcosa che ha
soprattutto
la funzione di essere guardata e quando
quello sguardo non trova a pagamento
allora quel corpo deve essere nascosto
siamo passati da non permette rai che
una strega viva che tutto sommato aveva
una sua maestosità con grandissima
scioltezza a non permetterà che una
donna grassa si metta uno scamiciato più
magre più belle e più curate sono gli
unici più che ci siano veramente
concessi la cosa che ti viene martellata
nel cervello quando sei una ragazza e
che a nessuno importa cosa pensi il
pensiero delle ragazze è sempre
trascurabile è irrilevante
a nessuno importa davvero cosa pensano
vogliono e desiderano le ragazze anzi
quando le ragazze prendono la parola
vengono aggredite pensate a greta
pensate a ma l'ala e ricordatevi che ma
l'ala è una che è sopravvissuta a 1 che
le ha sparato in testa
oh intendiamoci per le ragazze ci si
preoccupa tantissimo ci si preoccupa di
cosa indossano di come parlano di cosa
mangiano di chi frequentano ci si
preoccupa di dire loro che devono stare
attente che non devono uscire la notte
da sole che devono scegliere con cura le
persone da frequentare
intorno alle ragazze si costruisce un
muro solidissimo di piccole e grandi
limitazioni della libertà personale
perché là fuori è un brutto mondo
l'unica cosa di cui non ci si preoccupa
e fare il mondo in modo che i ragazzi
non siano il brutto mondo delle ragazze
da dietro questo muro in qualche modo
dovremmo imparare a essere leader
e se non ci riusciamo
se lasciamo la leadership ai maschi ci
viene detto che è colpa nostra che non
ci proponiamo che non siamo coraggiose
che non vogliamo emergere che preferiamo
restare nell'ombra
è qui che entra il femminismo in realtà
entra anche in altri lati dell'esistenza
perché non c'è lato davvero in cui il
femminismo non possa entrare e
riscrivere ribaltare e ricostruire tutto
il femminismo per chi si fosse perso le
puntate precedenti
nasce più o meno alla fine del 700 con
il pamphlet di milestone kraft che si
intitolava a vendica shaun wright woman
all'epoca le donne non mi erano niente
non possedevano niente non potevano
studiare non potevano lavorare fuori
casa non potevano votare buono kraft è
fra le prime a rivendicare il diritto
delle donne di essere umane di esistere
anche fuori dalle mura domestiche
da allora la teoria femminista si è
evoluta ha prodotto opere raffinatissime
ha cambiato obiettivo
difende ancora i diritti anche se i
diritti che difende sono cambiati non si
incarica più soltanto di tutelare il
nostro diritto a esistere in un mondo di
cui non scriviamo le regole ma si occupa
anche di riscrivere le regole di
renderle più eque e liberatoria per
tutti il femminismo non crea un mondo
anarchico crea un mondo in cui la
spartizione del potere sia sostituita
dalla condivisione e dalla della
conoscenza e delle risorse
collaborazione li dovete associa
competizione solidarietà al posto della
sopraffazione
chi non lo vorrebbe
è un sacco di gente
[Risate]
essere leader
essere donna mettersi alla testa di
qualcosa di un partito di un movimento
di un team professionale è una faccenda
complessa ed è ancora più complessa
perché dovunque si giri vede solo il
muro che le hanno costruito intorno non
si può essere leader va dietro un muro
leader non si nasce leader si diventa la
leadership è fatta di responsabilità
capacità di rischiare e di assumersi il
peso del rischio polso coraggio è tenuta
la leader femminista non si definisce
come tale per la sua capacità di
emergere ma per la capacità di
collaborare e creare a sua volta nuove
leader il femminismo non è occupazione
degli spazi e moltiplicazione degli
spazi delle voci dei punti di vista
man mano che si sale sulla scala del
prestigio
lo dicono le statistiche i maschi sono
sempre di più tutte le caratteristiche
che ho elencato come tratti distintivi
della buona leader vengono spazzati via
davanti alla leadership così come la
conosciamo che è competitiva
verticistica mai un dubbio un uomo solo
al comando come acab sulla tolda del
pequod ci ricordiamo tutti che ha fatto
fine ha fatto acab con tutto pequod vero
la leadership come la conosciamo la
leadership fragile basata sul culto
della personalità non sulla creazione e
condivisione di idee e una leadership
che gli uomini si trasmettono si
tramandano e si contendono in circoli
esclusivi in cui le uniche donne ammesse
sono quelle capaci di replicare
esattamente le stesse dinamiche di
sopraffazione conquista dell'avversario
succede in tutti gli ambienti lavorativi
più si sale più soldi ci sono più è
difficile per una donna farsi spazio in
una società che predilige l'aggressività
e la sicurezza di sé anche quando non è
sostenuta da capacità adeguate
certo anche le femmine sanno essere
tremende anzi la formula giusta è le
donne sono i peggiori nemiche le une
delle altre perché prima ti insegnano
che nella vita fanno strada solo quelli
che la affrontano con cattiveria
poi ti puniscono perché una donna non si
comporta così una donna con la d
maiuscola e gentile comprensiva
premurosa accogliente quello che in un
uomo normale temperamento e carattere in
una donna è essere stronza anzi
stronza con la s maiuscola e se la donna
a essere leader traspone sul superamento
di un grandissimo timore che è quello di
parlare in campo aperto invece di
picchiare nell'orecchio dell'uomo di
turno
avete presente no bevande donna dietro
il grande uomo
a questo proposito vorrei raccontarvi un
aneddoto sono almeno un paio d'anni che
mi trovo a parlare di femminismo e
questioni di genere in situazioni
pubbliche a volte anche molto pubbliche
è successo dopo che con il mio gruppo di
discussione femminista abbiamo lanciato
la campagna quella volta che che si è
occupata di aprire il discorso sulle
molestie sessuali in italia partendo
dalla rete
io mi sono incaricata di andare a
parlarne quindi sui giornali radio in
televisione
ovunque ce ne fosse necessità è un
lavoro impegnativo perché bisogna tenere
molto l'occhio sulla palla e non farsi
distrarre perché quando sei femminista
in pubblico la gente pretende che tu
salti come una foca ammaestrata quando
ti tira le sardine
al grido di dove sono le femministe
perché delle donne abbiamo un'idea
subalterna o dicono quello che vuoi tu
oppure non sono degni delle qualifiche
che si sono meritate per fare tutto
questo ho dovuto superare alcune grandi
paure
la prima era la paura di dire
stupidaggini in pubblico la seconda era
la paura di presentarmi come femminista
senza essere stata accreditata ad altre
femministe la terza era che la gente
potesse pensare che avevo ragione e
quindi decidesse di darmi credito e che
mi avrebbe posto nella posizione di
essere un riferimento per gli altri che
una posizione di grande responsabilità
insomma l'affare un incontro con le
scuole parlavo di femminismo come come
al solito
alla fine dell'incontro mi si avvicina
uno degli insegnanti e mi dice hai uno
stile di conduzione molto maschile
io non so che faccia ho fatto perché non
so mai che faccia faccio quando qualcuno
prende a riferimento allo stile dei
maschi per fargli un complimento
e siccome sono una donna sono state
educate essere gentile non me lo volevo
mangiare a disputare lì sul momento
anche avevo capito che lui voleva essere
gentile con me insomma la morale della
favola e questa passi tutta la tua vita
o buona parte della tua vita a imparare
a essere una donna ma all'atto pratico
quello che conta quando vai là fuori nel
mondo somigliare il più possibile a un
uomo
ho 46 anni impiegati almeno 30 a cercare
di diventare una donna
essendo io a dettare le condizioni ma
una cosa ho imparato a farla non ho più
paura della mia voce
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]